Let's see--we've learned that work and energy have an intimate relationship
namely that total work causes a change in kinetic energy and we see the energy is conserved.
The total amount never changes.
Now, what's really fascinating is that even though the total amount never changes,
energy can change forms and that's when potential energy comes in.
We can think of this as the potential to do work.
Now, I can think of what sort of situations involved potential energy.
It's often the case that things that are very frightening have high potential energy.
Which of these situations, tell me what you think has more potential energy?
A rock teetering in a high cliff versus a low,
a 12-volt car battery versus a small AA battery with 1.5 volts,
a lit stick of dynamite versus a lit twig, and a drawn bone arrow versus a relax one.